and more on the coronation the guardian
reports that new anti-protest laws will
be rushed through in time for Saturday
let's talk about that in more detail
should we join you guys now Tom
tugenhart minister of State for security
of the United Kingdom good to see you
thanks for joining us how worried about
you about what happened at the palace
last night look I'm always concerned
about security they're all family and of
course for a major event like this and
that's why we've spent quite literally
months planning it and I'm very glad to
see that the police reacted incredibly
quickly incredibly professionally to the
incident last night we're in no way
complacent and I'm very very proud of
the response that the police have done
the intelligence Services the police and
others have been working on this
extremely effectively for months what
can you tell us about what happened
you're going to understand there's very
little I can tell you other than what
you've already reported which is that an
incident occurred last night some
shotgun cartridges were thrown into the
palace grounds by an individual and that
individual has now been arrested
um pretty stupid given how many police
are on the street at the moment how much
is um security costing us for the
coronation
it's very difficult to pull that out as
a separate figure for the simple reason
that we've got an enormous amount of
effort going in for a major incident
like this in different parts of the
country because there's people getting
together in streets there's people
getting together in Gatherings across
the country which is because this is a
moment of national celebration
what I think is worth looking at though
is how much this is bringing to the
country if you look at the number of
tourists who are coming the number of
the amount of attention that's coming
and indeed I hope the amount of business
that will be generated by heads of state
and government and other business people
coming to the United Kingdom at this
time to see what we offer and this is a
fantastic moment to showcase the United
Kingdom to the world
um figures of at least 100 million just
for security is that a figure that you
recognize at all it's not a figure I
recognize sorry yeah so it's not going
to be that much it's look it's very
difficult to pull out these figures
because the government is paying for it
and thus we are paying for it as
taxpayers so they want to know how much
it's going to cost and it's a perfectly
reasonable question okay and forgive me
for not being able to break it down at
this point the reason I don't want to do
that is because there's police forces
around the country who are doing
different things and answer slightly
differently through their own different
structures so the Police Service in
Northern Ireland for example which is
going to have to do a lot of preparation
at the moment doesn't answer through the
home office through the Northern Ireland
office Police Service police Scotland
answers through the Scottish government
as you know so these are just slightly
different ways of calculating and I'm
sure we'll be able to come up with a
number but I don't have it at this time
how much it's costing the Met uh we
don't have that number now because I
haven't been collecting it what I've
been doing is making sure that the
matter ready and that means preparing
with them and the National Crime agency
and the intelligence services to make
sure they have all the resources they
need who are they most concerned about
um I'm so saying that Simon Morgan who's
a former Royal Protection Officer
suggesting that the biggest threat is
homegrown with people like Extinction
Rebellion just stop oil suggestions that
they're going to throw rape alarms at
parading horses which seems pretty
ridiculous so first of all you'll
understand what I don't want to do is to
encourage anybody or give anybody ideas
so I'm not going to highlight
individuals what I would say though is
that we have spent an awful lot of time
over the last several months preparing
for any number of different threats
because the reality is this is a very
complex event first of all as you know
there's the parade down the mouse which
is relatively contained then we've got
the concert in Windsor and then of
course we've got events around the
country I know I don't know about you
but I'm going to be a street party on
Sunday and there are many different ways
in which we're looking to make sure that
people and communities around the
country are absolutely safe and what
would you say to those groups that are
potentially considering trying to
disrupt events by throwing rape alarms
at parading horses so I'd say to anybody
who's thinking of uh doing anything like
that think of your fellow citizens think
of your friends your family and your
neighbors think of what this is about
for many many people this is a moment
when the country can come together
whether you're a royalist whether you're
not this is a moment where you can
celebrate the family the community that
you're in you can celebrate what it
means to be British in a in an open in a
in a caring way and make sure that
you're there for each other I think this
is a huge opportunity for the country
and it's a major moment for us to come
together and I think that's something to
celebrate our post bag is absolutely
brimming with people saying that they
that Camilla is not their Queen what
would you say well I'd say it's not for
me to choose who the king marries and
the King chose to marry Camilla and so I
respect his choice and I'm very much
looking forward to
meeting her one day as Queen are you
going to be in are you going to The
Abbey I'm very lucky I have been invited
you are lucky actually only 2 000 or so
as opposed to 8 000 back in 1953. let me
move on to um Sudan Moore rescues today
which are almost airlifts today
um are we too little too late no we're
not this has been the longest uh and the
largest Rescue Mission by any Western
Country I think I'm going to get the
figures slightly out but I think it's
about 2 300 people have been airlifted
out there's another flight today from
Port Sudan and I think the uh the the
ministry of defense and the foreign
office have done an exceptional job in
responding very quickly to what turned
into a crisis very uh surprisingly at a
moment when we thought peace talks would
take off but they didn't now what's
happening is the foreign officers are
devoting huge amounts of effort making
sure the ceasefire such as it could be
is re-established and uh with any luck
we're able to deliver a safer outcome
for everybody in Khartoum and Sudan and
those who are not lucky enough to be
able to be airlifted out and find
themselves on a small boat crossing the
channel what should happen to them when
they get here so there are already many
who've come from Sudan through different
resettlement schemes that are lawful and
legal family resettlement the Sudanese
community in the UK is the one of the
largest to use the family resettlement
scheme and there's also the UK
resettlement scheme which in previous
years has taken unhcr resettlement so
there are legal ways in which those who
have a Justified reason for asylum in
the United Kingdom can take it and they
really should not be empowering people
traffickers or organize crime groups by
using illegal means of course it's not
illegal though is it well the organized
crime groups that are operating the
channel on a boat is not illegal but it
is wrong to subsidize or support in any
way organize crime groups and I don't
think any of us would support the idea
that we should have organized crime
groups profiting from Human misery and
sadly that's what we're seeing in the
channel and that's what we're seeing in
the Mediterranean acknowledge it's not
illegal don't we find a small vote what
we acknowledge is that organized crime
groups are making an absolute Fortune
out of human misery and this is deeply
wrong it's a form of human trafficking
that has brought misery to quite
literally millions you know we see is it
illegal on a small boat across the
channel okay we see
it's not illegal to be a victim of human
trafficking thank you but it's not
illegal but it is illegal to to
transport people in a criminal way and
that's what we're seeing okay but
a question and you acknowledge that it's
not illegal to cross the channel in a
small boat what about putting these
people on disused oil rigs is that a
good idea
so there's a huge number of solutions
that we've got to come to uh that we've
got to find for this because what we
simply cannot have is this form of human
trafficking that is literally costing
thousands of lives a year I mean quite
understandably K you're focused on the
channel and I understand why because
that's most the closest area to the
United Kingdom but if you look at the
passage of migration through the Sahara
Desert through the Mediterranean there
are quite literally thousands and
thousands of bodies marking the evil of
this crime down every step of that route
we have got to stop this this is a
simple humanitarian
uh
emergency in many parts of the world and
we've got to make sure that people are
not trafficked into this human misery it
is absolutely horrific to see what it's
done to some individuals who all they're
doing is searching for better life but
what they're doing what happens to them
is they get sold into slavery sold into
human trafficking and many of them sadly
are murdered effectively in the Sahara
and the Mediterranean and thus should we
put these people on disused oil rigs
well what we should do is stop the
traffic what we've got to do is we've
got to make sure that this crime doesn't
pay and the way in which to make sure
this crime doesn't pay is to make sure
there is no incentive to do it now there
are safe and legal routes I've just
highlighted two of them for you there's
the community resettlement and there's a
mandate resettlement as well so there
are safe and legal routes into the
United Kingdom these are not the safe
and legal groups okay let me just ask
you quickly before I let you go about
the Ukrainian Ambassador who is that
where you are uh yesterday saying that
he still wants these fighter jets uh
from the UK and other countries in order
to try to defeat Russia are we going to
let them have them so if an imprison
psycho has been one of the most
effective advocates for his country and
we have been absolutely front and you
know the Forefront of making sure that
he gets all the ammunition support he
needs we've been absolutely key to huge
amounts of cooperation in ways that I'm
not going to discuss but also in ways
that we can discuss things like training
where you see the Ukrainian forces being
trained in Salisbury Plain and the
weapons and ammunition going forward the
question about fighter jets is a
slightly different one because it
requires huge amounts of Maintenance to
sustain a fighter jet for every hour
it's in the air you've got to service
the parts and the engines and all the
different bits of it for many many hours
on the ground so it's not as simple as
simply sending over a shell or giving a
piece of information or training a
soldier and that's why the complexity of
this is so great so what would be the
best on would be to make sure that
they're able to maintain the Jets they
already have because they have the
training and they have the experience to
do that and make sure that they're able
to take on and defeat the Russian forces
that are attacking them what we should
also be doing is looking at making sure
they have air defense and that is
exactly what we're doing we're making
sure that they have the weapon system
that means that Russian aircraft cannot
attack them and that after all is
absolutely essential to making sure the
ukrainians are in a position to actually
spell Russia from there at a time
Saturday so I'm going to have to let you
go
um lucky you for having a ticket on
Saturday give us a wave as you go in I
will do thank you very much indeed
thanks a lot Mr Chicken hunt